we are on the
kern river preserve
it's beautiful to walk on the preserve
this time of year the mornings are
really cool
this time of year is also amazing
because you're hearing all the bird song
earlier in the morning
the willow flycatcher is this small
plane bird
[Music]
and it flies around and catches flies
because that's the type of insect it
eats the most
and it nests near rivers or creeks
[Music]
[Applause]
knowing their vocalizations is key to
doing the research because otherwise
you'd rarely see them if you didn't
they say what the flycatchers do is fit
spew
you wouldn't even call it a song really
i mean it's it's okay it doesn't sound
bad
i love it when i hear it because there's
means there's a willow flycatcher
nearby so
definitely
i've lived here in the kern river valley
since
the winter of 1990.
when i first started working here there
were more willow flycatchers
and now it's it's down to about
as far as we know at this point in time
one individual
that's all we know of right now and it's
kind of depressing
[Music]
as a whole impindex trailii the willow
flat catcher is not endangered in fact
it's relatively abundant
in north america
however the subspecies that inhabits the
southwestern united states is federally
endangered because of rapid and steep
population declines over the latter half
of the 20th century
basically i view the willow flycatcher
as a
canary in a coal mine it's not doing
well so why is it not doing well here
and if you can solve that for the will
of flycatcher it's probably going to
prevent other bird species from having
the same problems later on
in the u.s there's roughly 100 species
of neotropical migratory bird that are
either threatened endangered or a
species of special concern
a neo-tropical migrant is a bird that
breeds in north america and then
migrates south of the us border into the
into the neotropics
before i really began to study migration
in detail i tended to think of these
birds as our birds they're in the north
american field guide they must be north
american birds right
but they spend in most cases more than
half the year
south of the u.s border
of the nearly 800 species of birds that
breed in north america
about half
migrate into the neotropics it's just a
it's a huge number
so if you observe that a migratory bird
species is declining one of the first
questions you have to ask
is whether it's declining due to factors
on the breeding grounds in north america
the wintering grounds in the neotropics
or somewhere in between or a combination
of those
[Music]
the main reason why it's hard to figure
out why some of these species are in
trouble is because they're only in our
backyards for say three months of the
year and the rest of the time we don't
know where they're going so we don't
know what threats they're facing in
those areas
in order to develop conservation
strategies we need to be able to
identify how breeding and wintering
populations are linked
so migratory bird conservation has to be
a collaborative effort with biologists
all over latin america
more than 220 species of birds actually
migrate mostly from north america to
costa rica
birds know no borders they don't
understand these boundaries between
countries they simply use ecosystems
there are huge networks of people that
do bird banding all over the western
hemisphere so you capture the birds in a
misnet and you put a little metal leg
band on the bird and then you hope to
recapture that bird at some other point
in its annual cycle
but the recapture rates are incredibly
low they're less than one percent
so our thought was
well if we could develop a technology
that could use information within a
single feather
like information in the dna of the bird
to track the migratory movements then we
can take a feather collected from
anywhere
along the migratory journey and link it
back to which breeding population that
came from
the bird gene escape project is an
effort to use genomic sequencing to
understand the population specific
movements of migratory birds
[Music]
the original idea came from the
co-director of the bird gene escape
project tom smith
who literally just
decided
about 20 years before the technology was
actually available that we should be
able to do this
in the early
90s i naively thought that
well if we just collect some feathers
we'll be able to get dna out of feathers
and
it took the the human genome project to
really develop the tools
to enable us to begin to link
populations
so i live in colorado now
but if i wanted to know where my
ancestors came from i might send my dna
off to a genetic ancestry service
they would compare my dna against this
huge
database of dna from many many other
people and be able to identify that most
of my ancestry is from norway which is
where i know my grandparents came from
we can do the same thing with the bird
gene escape project
we collaborate with these bird banding
stations which are all over
north america and latin america
to collect feathers
and then our first step is essentially
creating that ancestry database
when we sequence the genome from birds
all across the breeding range we use
that to build a map of how the different
birds
are related to one another and what the
unique genetically unique populations
are across the breeding range
and then we can take a feather collected
from outside of its breeding range and
we can compare that with the expected
genetic profile of of birds from
different parts of the breeding range
and we can tell you that this bird is
actually a bird that might be found
breeding in the sierra nevada mountains
or
new york or something like that
which is really cool
[Music]
my specific role in the bird genoscape
project is collecting genetic samples of
willow flycatchers throughout their
wintering range and then also the the
breeding grounds as well
my role is the fun stuff i think
[Music]
i have a speaker
and i'm going to use it to do some
playback of the willow flycatcher
vocalizations in order to lure it into
the net
i use a long cord so i'm a good distance
away from the net
and i won't scare them
where'd it go
[Music]
yep
that's him
he was a feisty one but we got him
[Music]
so this is a willow flycatcher
he's not happy he's a very feisty guy
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is one of the most important things is
to have the genetic samples
so i'm going to pluck the tail feather
first
sorry guy
the general sort of description of where
the willow flycatcher winters from bird
books is
from mexico down to
the northern tip of south america
when the southwestern willow flycatcher
was listed as endangered we had no idea
where this particular subspecies winter
did it go throughout that whole range or
just a portion of the range we had no
idea
once we have developed
what we call the gene escape the map of
how populations are
related on the breeding grounds we can
take any individual captured on the
wintering areas or anywhere along its
migratory trajectory and tell you where
that bird was from
so the end product of
the bird gene escape project for a
particular species
is the creation of a map that
details the
genetically distinct lineages and where
they're found on the breeding range
similar to the kind of map that you
would find in a bird book but in this
case it's population specific and then
it also details where those different
populations which migratory routes they
use and then where they're found on the
wintering grounds
the virgin escape project was able to
show us with
high precision
where the wintering areas of the
southwestern willow flycatcher are so
people have dedicated their lives to
knowing where this bird spends the
winter
and we know now that it winters in
specific areas in costa rica and
nicaragua so now we can really focus
our efforts to where they're needed
which is super cool that's the whole
point
right now we have just for the
neo-tropical migrants about 200 000
feathers
so that represents roughly around 100 or
so species
right now we're working on
roughly 20 species of migratory birds
and they're in various stages of
development
our
long-term goal is to map 100
species of migratory birds of higher
conservation concern by the year 2025
the collaboration is growing if we go
back to the early 90s it was myself and
my graduate students in my lab
and now you know we have
many many collaborators
from from across north americans in
central america
we know where the birds are and where to
get the samples what we're doing right
now is just adding one extra fuel which
is collect the feather and send it back
to the states for us that's very little
but for the birds that's huge
and that's our win-win relationship with
the bird gene escape project
the ultimate goal is really creating a
network
a franchise if you will of different
universities different research groups
all coming together to
to solve these mysteries of migratory
birds that's my hope
i think the willow flycatcher is a
fantastic example of why the work is so
important
it enables conservation to be targeted
to those places in most need
if the southwestern willow flycatcher
went extinct i think a lot of people
they drug their shoulders and say well
that doesn't you know matter a whole lot
but i think the decline of the
southwestern willow flycatcher is is
kind of an alarm call and and if it
disappears it's it's a huge warning that
that there's something wrong
[Music]
[Music]
i think birds bring people together
it is like when you go to another
country and you realize that someone
speaks the same language and you can
have like endless conversations uh just
because you speak the same language
for us is the language of bird
conservation
[Music]
i think one of the great outcomes of the
project is is connecting the people
who are working on the same birds but in
different parts
of the world at different seasons
in a way that couldn't happen before
because we didn't know where the birds
were going
that makes me really happy
it's the same birds in your backyard
in guatemala that are in my backyard in
colorado
we're all sort of working toward the
same goal with the same species and it's
just it couldn't be more clear that we
all need to be on the same page working
together
[Music]
you